على خطط تويتر تسير متى نحو احد عشر الف
موظف في طريقهم لفقد وظائفهم بعد قرار
رئيس الشركه مارك زوكربيرج عاصفه سلكوم
فالي تطالب متى في فتره مضطربه تمر بها
الشركه حيث فقدت مليارات الدولارات من
قيمه اسهم هذا العام تراجع اداء عكسه
تباطئ نموها عالميا في مواجهه تيك توك
التي تتصاعد بقوه في عالم الشبكات
الاجتماعيه الى جانب تراجع عدد من
المؤمنين الرقميين عن الانفاق على منصات
الشركه بسبب ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وعدم
استقرار الاسواق عمليه تسريحتها تعد
الاكبر من نوعها في تاريخ الشركه البالغ
عدد موظفها 87 الفنا وهو ما دفع مارك
زوكربيرج الى مخاطبه الموظفين في رساله
ممزوجه بمسحه اعتذار ووعود بالاصلاح
اريد ان اتحمل المسؤوليه عن هذه القرارات
وكيف وصلنا الى هنا اعرف ان هذا صعب على
الجميع وانا اسف بشكل خاص للمتاثرين
قرارات اضافيه تتجه مثل اتخاذها وفق بيان
مركز كربرج من بينها ان تصبح الشركه اصغر
حجما واكثر كفاءه من خلال خفض الانفاق الى
جانب تمديد قرار وقف عمليات التوظيف
وفقا للخبراء فان قرارات ذكر اللورد تتعرض
مع نيته زياده الانفاق والتوسع في بناء
عالم متوفرز الافتراضي والاستثمار في
ادواته التقنيه
نهج جديد في اداره كبرى الشركات
التكنولوجيه العملاقه قد يلحق بركبه اخرون
لكنه في الوقت ذاته يعاكس اختبارا صعبا
ورهانا قد تظهر نتائجها اما الخروج من
الازمه او مزيد من القرارات الصعبه علي
السمان العربيه